to many gamers out there there's only
one thing more important than victory
and that is having
dope ass skins nah the reavers dog dude
River straight dog fans uses that up
why don't you say that in the first
place but having the latest and greatest
Cosmetics isn't enough if you take
yourself seriously as a connoisseur you
must also have the rarest skins
imaginable oh my god oh let's go so it
should come as no surprise that many of
us dish out our hard-earned cash to have
just a slim chance of unboxing some of
Gaming's most coveted items ah thank you
so much MacGyver it means a lot there is
a giveaway from Adam transfer because
serious and no game Stokes our obsession
with rare and unique skins quite like
csgo
oh
[Music]
okay who got a knife huh I did but even
among the most degenerate one man has
risen as CS goes most let's say
energetic skin Enthusiast
sexy baseball please
foreign
I mean it could have been worse meat on
a pixel a German skin obsessed CS go die
hard who recently became one of the
community's most beloved content
creators both for his deeply relatable
love of rare skins and for his
Meek personality
the hole is always right there and it's
sometimes in scratchy worse the float
the dirtier the whole and the hole is
always in the middle of the screen right
this is why you want to have a clean
hole like this one but how did on his
obsession with skins help him stand out
in a sea of cosmetic consumed content
creators and how is he even able to
diversify his content while still
remaining one of the game's most
passionate fanboys
are you ready yes let's get it off
okay so before we start talking about
onay and skins I gotta remind you to
please head over to shop.thescore.com
and check out our merch we got cool
Esports hoodies we got t-shirts in tons
of different colors and sizes and you
don't need luck to get these ones you
just need a credit card okay so these
days on a pixel is twitch's Premiere
unhinged CS go streamer AKA for convincy
AKA baby please please pay me please
there's no way but before he was
twitch's hottest DJ getting his
Instagram rated by an adult film actress
and opening cases strapped to a heart
rate monitor one was just your average
CS Die Hard which of course meant that
he was
obsessed with skins of course I've
always loved the game all aspects of the
game I've always played the game
um you could say that half of my Alice
in CS I don't know how many hours I have
right now
um is probably just me inspecting skins
looking at skins in fact he's session
led him to start uploading videos to
YouTube discussing some of csgo's rarest
and most infamous skins and right out of
the gate it was obvious that on his
approach to content creation was a bit
raw how do I stop this
hey guys what's going on that's only
Pixar here but thanks to his deep
understanding of the skin Market his own
impressive collection and the fact that
he was making content that helped his
fans make better Investments one amassed
a small following of other aspiring skin
enthusiasts that growth skyrocketed once
he started collaborating with larger CS
go content creators such as anomaly and
it was during a meet-up in Sweden and
Iceland where the Cs go masses got a
taste for what made honest so special
show them how the Germans do it
dumb he's thinking though God damn
motion
that was just not worth it
being exposed to anomalies much larger
audience helped on his own audience on
Twitch grow even more but again this
dude was a bit of an oddball and he
wasn't doing anything particularly
original so what was it that was getting
people so into one sure getting signal
boosted by a guy with millions of
subscribers helps but it still doesn't
explain why people kept tuning in he
wasn't a former pro or an analyst and
people sure as hell weren't tuning in
for his gameplay no man
I take a second to focus I take a second
to like rethink about this game and then
I and then I will uh top track from
it's the remarkable thing about owning
he
[Music]
some ways
it is interested in skins as they are in
the game itself we are fascinated by
them spend heinous amounts of money to
get our hands on the coolest ones and
even keep track of which ones are
popular amongst the pros and one is the
biggest fanatic of assault his
excitement about skins is both unmatched
and infectious don't know if I agree
with that I don't know if my gold one
has been to that great recently I mean I
did unbox the second worst of the cases
and the second most set of gloves in
Cisco history
that was a theme
[Applause]
this is not real this
is not real
average CS go skin Fanboy ascended he
cares about skins more than just about
anybody on this Earth and that's what
got people watching
and his
out there streaming Persona don't
disrespect skins that you don't use a
lot your inventory is your house it's
your safe space and you have these
little children in your house right
there there you're okay that sounds
totally okay bro you're like you have
you know like Okay Okay let's listen
eating a banana on banana Inferno eating
postpartum puts it to use a donut on
donut and it shows me eating a donut on
Ancient Donuts eating a cat no no not
that one eating a uh the winner of the
game oh my God I want to be there right
now oh Iceland suck me dry oh my God
Chad I'm melting right now I'm melting
like a white piece of chocolate but
there is actually one other super subtle
reason for on his recent rampant
popularity and that is that he started
streaming at exactly the right moment
you see during the pandemic CS goes
player count exploded meaning that there
were tons of new fans looking to learn
about both the game and its massive
world of cosmetics and with his big
personality one was just that guy he was
funny he was knowledgeable and most
importantly his stream was a place
people could go to watch someone slowly
descend into Madness by blowing
thousands of dollars on cases do some
quick roads I will never do quick rolls
I hate quick rolling
quick open is one of the most Degen
stupidest things quick open
28 year old man going crazy
and on his always had an eye for some of
the more Infamous skins on the market
which he was always willing to share
some Insider knowledge about with the
uninitiated we all know the five seven
pattern no let me give you a little
brain refresh just in case I can't show
it for too long because I'm live some of
you may know this pattern some of you
have may have even seen it in real life
the five seven Kami with a
in the back we all know this pattern how
much is this uh pattern worth usually
round about booty how much were your
[__] patterns again I think 100 a
hundred dollars a hundred dollars honest
interests extended beyond the salacious
however those who tuned in regularly
knew that his real Obsession lay with cs
Go's rarest items more specifically 2014
katowice Holo stickers and particular
scar pattern blue gems to translate that
into English one is into skins that cost
unfathomable amounts of money he told me
to reach out to him with an offer of
1.2 million in Bitcoin and I'm not
talking about USD I'm talking about
Euros which converts to 1.5 million USD
he answered not interested 1.2 million
is low eventually thanks in part to his
wacky personality and his willingness to
spend exorbitant sums to keep us all
entertained on his popularity outgrew
this fairly Niche part of the Cs
Community memes and clips of his streams
spread across the internet like Molly
fire and Ona quickly became one of the
game's most recognizable Representatives
plus his stream became one of the go-to
places for watch parties where you could
enjoy CS Go's highest level of gameplay
with the most insane man in the
community last chance
just getting
worse
oh
I bet my brain had to think for a second
the thing is when your entire brand is
built around losing your mind and
spending insane amounts of money
one-upping yourself can be sort of a
challenge this is why after co-streaming
the grand finals of pro League season 16
onay decided to open up his most
expensive items to date a 2015
Cobblestone souvenir case and a 2014
kataviza sticker capsule that he got
from a wealthy viewer two items that
cost more than most people make in
months and could turn exponential
profits with the right click so with
many many thousands of dollars on the
line on I did what any sane person would
do and strapped on a heart rate monitor
comments on package from karovic
2015. three two
one
servers
there was a 700 capsule we unboxed 40
cents as disappointing as that was next
up was the real deal a 12 000 capsule
that could potentially quadruple on his
return on investment if the correct
sticker was unboxed the question was did
on a have luck on his side led to my
inventory now tight no the police come
on
three two one
fight Nola
oh
my God
the cheapest sticker off the capsule
right next to a Titan yes yes poorone
missed the Titan Hollow by mere
millimeters which of course is just a
visual thing but
but tragic as that was when you're
watching someone else open cases
the outcome Almost Doesn't Matter for
some weird psychological reason humans
find a sort of morbid joy in another's
misery and Oni getting the worst
possible outcome makes for great goddamn
content oh
Chad now just imagine imagine we opened
the kettle 14 capsule 12 000 and it does
that with the Titan and lands on a
nipple
oh my God
and just to Twist the knife a fan ended
up opening one of honors covered in
Titan Hollows just a few weeks later
here we go Titan hold on Titan hold on
I'm happy I'm so happy
way no
no but there was a silver lining in this
whole situation for obvious reasons
opening a 12 000 case is going to
attract some attention must admit I'm a
bit disappointed stickers on these guns
look at this gold Arabesque you know
yeah no stickers on it dude
yeah I mean at least put an nip one on
there owner pixel will know about that
one all too well
on a grew and grew averaging over 10 000
viewers on most days during the Rio
major and on those days he gave the
people exactly what they wanted highbrow
skin talk tons of case openings
and some absolutely [__] unhinged
commentary oh popcorn hopefully helps
our scene to develop oh I want something
so is that a car trying to get through
or is it the Crowd Oh a banana cover it
they keep it under control what an
inaugural experience
he's trying to like push there away you
know when you eat crisps chips at home
all the residue goes down into your
keyboard if you have it all goes into
the middle wasd the buttons that you're
using if you ever Twisted it avoids that
it goes around like Mass fix so in a
world of your regular old CS go streams
one is a breath of fresh air he's one of
us a regular dude who just loves skins
and we're all just along for the ride
and as far as his skill on the server
goes let's just say he's improving at
his own pace
oh
bro what the [__] what's happening
why is everyone talking when I'm trying
to clutch
[Music]
but make no mistake one is not some
buffoon who got lucky he played his
cards perfectly rising to the top of
csgo's crowded Creator Space by making
the right moves at the right time Fame
hasn't changed on it though when he
drops thousands on cases he isn't just
doing it for us
doing it because
well he might legitimately have a
problem please
okay I mean it could have been worse in
a sense what makes honest so special is
that there's a little part of him in all
of us when you truly love CS go you love
every part of it The Good the Bad and
the Ugly one is a CS go Fanatic in every
sense of the word he and his community
share an unrelenting connection to six
skins the pro scene and the Pains of
matchmaking Ona is the quintessential CS
go fan and trust me when I say that
there is no other esport in the world
that could make him a superstar it's one
thing to see like a message a chat
message pop up and it's like a username
and so on right there's another thing
when you actually see someone like
holding a sign inside of an arena I
never never ever would have thought that
this would turn into something like this
where I get to do what I do
oh that makes me so happy right now so
happy
whenever he's co-streaming no matter who
he's watching doesn't matter who it is
Could Be Theory could be astralis it
could be a [__] liquid it doesn't
matter he just starts speaking in the
collective first person Chet device in
the 1v3 he can do he can do it for us
like every time and he gets so we're at
Chet we need this round that's the
chance we need this this is big for us
chat he's so good dude